I think you may be the best storyteller
in Hollywood over all the years that we
go out to dinner and you talk about the
different celebrities you've met and
you're so funny about them and it got me
thinking today seriously what do you
think is one of your I know Frank
Sinatra was one and you've told me that
story but what's one of your biggest
celebrity encounters of all time where
you were kind of probably new on the
scene and just just kind of blown away
that you were actually talking to this
legend
well I remember at the first time I went
to an award show it was January of 1980
mm-hmm and it was the Golden Globes and
I had never been to an award show and my
wife and I were sitting I remember
sitting with Marilu Henner and then she
later told me who else was there because
I can't remember she remembers
everything and but John Travolta was
sitting at her too and it was like
unbelievable you know Hamilton Ontario
and suddenly I see Al Pacino who is just
that's my accent yes but you know yeah
and I go up to him and I'm in a tux
tonight I'm 29 and I look about you know
20 yeah and I go up and say mr. Pacino I
just have to say that you are the
greatest actor in the world you inspire
people you make people want to be an
actor and your work is beyond
comprehension and you're not doing sin
thank you
I ordered a Stoli about 25 minutes I'm
kind of getting impatient for it so he
thought it was a waiter
and I didn't know how to tell him I
wasn't yeah yeah yeah I said okay Kay
mr. Pacino all fighters I get you you
drink Pacino no but it is always
daunting to meet and who's the biggest
hero you've ever met
he's right here no really from your
child I would say I would say it was in
the late 80s and early 90s and lorn
at starting out live invited Robert
smile and I out to dinner and he just
sort of mentioned we might be joined by
some people when Robert smile and I are
writers on sent out live and I'm now 24
and and all of a sudden I just see a hey
how's it going everybody chit and it's
Paul McCartney and he sits down with us
and he's with his wife Linda and I'm I
mean I don't just I'm not just a Beatles
fan I know every song I play the guitar
I obsessed with them and I found myself
immediately bloomers like Robert and
Conan are working on a TV pilot
Conan explained it to Paul like first
thing he said and and Paul's just like
oh okay what and he's looking at me and
I'm like it's show about did do things
in there people and then at one point I
said something like but that's kinda
what we're doing with you know it's a
little depression making something I
mean when I was with the Beatles you
know when the people with big bags and
money came along we had already had
together so we were okay but we were
already worked it out in the clubs and
he started talking about John and
everything and you just you can't
believe just diarrhea everywhere yeah
well it was him I don't know why he was
nice imagery yeah to add a little image
there at the end that's a wonderful
story you know I was going to say that
you know golden rule of show business
just because someone asks you a question
doesn't mean they need an answer
yes mr. short yeah
write that down 12 times
you